En ces temps de confinement, nous sommes sûrement très nombreux à ouvrir ce genre de petites boîtes,
pour déguster celles qui sont confinées à l’intérieur depuis parfois plusieurs années.
L’invention de la boîte de conserve
a révolutionné l’alimentation.
Elle permet de conserver les aliments
pendant très longtemps.
C’est un Français qui a mis la technique au point :
Nicolas Appert, en 1795.
La technique consiste à chauffer les aliments
à 100°C au bain-marie pour détruire les bactéries.
Des aliments que l’on a placés au préalable dans une boîte étanche pour éviter d’être contaminés à nouveau.
Les petits pois sont les premiers légumes
à avoir été mis en conserve.
Vous allez comprendre pourquoi.
A l’origine la boite n’était pas métallique.
Elle était en verre.
Nicolas Appert utilisait des bouteilles de champagne.
Les seules à pouvoir résister à la pression,
liée à la dilatation de l’air à l’intérieur
au moment du chauffage.
Alors évidemment… avec des sardines,
c’est beaucoup moins facile à remplir.
La boite de sardines a quant à elle été inventée en 1823,
par un certain Monsieur Colin.
Sardine, colin, ça ne s’invente pas…
Quant à cette « capsule de déconfiné »,
je vous conseille de la consommer fraîche.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir les vidéos
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Et pour n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.